opening arguments officially begin today
in former president trump's second
impeachment trial
now yesterday house impeachment managers
drew a direct line
between the ex-president's words and the
violence on january
6. while mr trump's defense attorneys
were met with bipartisan
confusion is a word people are using
today nancy cordes was on capitol hill
during the riot she's back there now
with more on this story nancy good
morning it was quite a day yesterday
it really was gail and today what we are
going to see is the house impeachment
managers
lay out their case that this building
may have been
attacked a month ago and you can still
see that it's heavily
guarded today but they are going to
argue that actually the president's role
goes back
much farther than that to when he first
began claiming
that this election was rigged that it
was stolen that it was fraudulent
they are going to say that it wasn't
simply an errant comment here or there
but a campaign of lies that led to an
uprising from his followers that left
half a dozen people dead presidents
can't inflame insurrection in their
final weeks
and then walk away like nothing happened
the house managers previewed their
argument yesterday
we are going to the capitol where our
problems are
it's that direction
using a powerful video that walked
senators through the assault on their
own chamber
and we fight we fight like hell along
with
mr trump's actions before and after we
love you
you're very special he celebrated their
cause
he validated their attack he told them
remember
this day forever mr trump's defense
got off on the wrong foot we changed
what we were going to do
on account that we thought that the
house manager's presentation
was well done lawyer bruce castor who
specializes in
medical malpractice and personal injury
cases
kept diverging from the issue at hand
nebraska you're going to hear
is quite a judicial
thinking place we still know what
records are right
on the thing you put the needle down on
and play senators called it
rambling a rocky start even
inappropriate
and those were just the republicans
president trump's team
were disorganized they did everything
they could but to talk about the
question at hand
still just one of them louisiana's bill
cassidy
changed his position joining five other
republicans who voted with democrats to
let the trial go forward
the house managers made a compelling
cogent
case and the president's team
did not leading the house manager's case
is maryland's jamie raskin
who described that day in personal terms
the risk to his daughter and son-in-law
who were with him at the capitol she
said dad
i don't want to come back to the capitol
of all the terrible brutal things i saw
and i heard on that day
and since then that one hit me the
hardest
the house impeachment managers will have
their first of two eight-hour days today
to lay out their case and then the
defense
gets the same amount of time followed by
questioning from the senators themselves
who remember
all too well what happened here a little
over a month ago because they were among
the targets tony nancy thank you very
much